in the Synod the heart of Welsh
democracy they didn't want us
overhearing any tricky political
conversations
instead it was football that tripped him
up as he was asked if he was supporting
England or Wales
rugby and that's my kind of way of being
is I have this book well over England
and the work and saying I've got to be
able to play like you know casually in
my information because I worry otherwise
about some drops if that is
for Wales the World Cup is a big deal
the first time in 64 years that they've
made it
so the fact that William has showed so
much public support for the England team
even as president of the fa hasn't gone
down well with some
including Welsh actor Michael Sheen who
tweeted not a shred of embarrassment or
sensitivity to the problem here hashtag
Prince of Wales
it's also played into the hands of those
who didn't even want another Prince and
Princess of Wales last month a motion
was raised in Gwynedd Council to have
the title abolished by plied Camry
councilor elvid Wynn app elwin it's like
an open wound you know um
uh a lot of people still see the title
of the Prince of Wales as a symbol of
Wales being subjugated it doesn't then
present the culture it doesn't represent
the language it just doesn't represent
the nation
the prince's team would argue that he
wants to be authentic and would we
really expect him to swap allegiances
when he's always been an England fan but
on a day about building relationships
not showing more obvious support for
Wales felt like an own goal Rhiannon
Mills Sky News